[Music]
when they at marketing asked us to give
a talk Christian Dale and I said only if
we can be the last session on the last
day Thank You marketing no but you
obviously clearly are committed to
security and so we have I think a very
interesting talk here just out of
curiosity how many of you have heard of
beyond Corp Google's beyond Corp story
okay there's some hands for those of you
who haven't I'm sorry you wouldn't come
otherwise that's how good the stories
just for those of you who haven't heard
of beyond Corp just a brief and we'll
get into the details here in a minute
this is a model a security posture that
Google started going through about five
to seven years ago what we decided that
the traditional model of security
doesn't work for Google anymores but any
company where the employees are
scattered all over the world you know
VPNs are really not the way to answer
those questions anymore so we'll talk
about those in detailed imma meet a
Christian will come shortly and I me a
Dale from ventas de who's going to give
us a lot of detail into what those guys
did around the vision and how some of
our tooling helps them get there so
that's like what we're talking about
today so i will i will quickly review
the beyond corp stuff we want to talk
about some of the new products we've
launched that would help customers get
this vision delivered so we'll talk
about the identity where proxy which you
may have heard yesterday towards talked
about and then Christian will talk
through the security key and then we
want to leave a lot of time here for
Dale to come up I think there is a
really interesting story about how
fantastic went through there's change in
security architecture how they started
implementing all this and he likes
questions so he asked me explicitly to
tell you to ask him lots of questions so
let's get started I wanted to quickly
review what beyond Corp really means
what it means to you the enterprise we
think of this is really context to where
secure access so as we dive into that
let me let me start with a little bit of
and this is the way that Google did it I
think this is the way a lot of our
customers are going to this model now
right the traditional model of security
is what we call the wall guardant
approach you have an employee who has to
access exciting and interesting
information and applications we make
them go through a VPN right no matter
where they sit we make them go to this
tiresome cumbersome high latency VPN and
then they can get access to all their
applications that model starts to break
down of course as all of you know when
you start to introduce new use
and new devices rights you introduce a
contractor who's not necessarily
corporate employee and potentially the
users that are coming out of mobile
devices getting because applications
that comes harder and harder in that
model right and when you do extend that
model to fit for contractors and mobile
devices you find you have unintended
consequences here you have a contractor
who's supposed to be accessing the CRM
system but what they're in essence
you're allowing them to access
everything including the ERP system so
the walled garden serve gets breached in
this model the evolution of what we're
going through now sort of even more
complicate this modeled so you're not
taking these applications that at least
used to be behind a VPN and now you're
putting them in a cloud hopefully our
cloud since you're here but many of you
are putting them in many clouds right
it's another security model and access
model starts to really break down and
how this world works and then and then
finally what you move some of our
leading customers are starting to do is
start to move identity into the cloud as
well so there's no more on prem ID or
it's becoming a secondary thing we're
really now identity lives in the cloud
as well so everything in essence is on
the internet you're in multiple places
of multiple applications securing access
to all of this world becomes very very
complicated and so what we what that
does is it introduces a whole set of new
risk right there's many many here but I
wanted to highlight some of the key ones
and I think this is the key takeaway
side right there are lots of things that
we start to interest as problems and we
need to your vendors or you need to
start introducing solution for these
problems so the first one let start I
mean we can start the very beginning
right that employ themselves are they
really who they say they are are they
right using the right credentials if
somebody stole in those credentials you
think Oh teepees are safe but those are
just bearer tokens in essence right so
somebody can come steal that and use
that as well so now you have to worry is
this the user that they say they are
even if the user is who they say they
are if they're using a device that's
compromised they're using a personal
device that has a lot of malware on it
what you're finding is that whatever
data is accessed the application the
device has access to is not stolen data
right and we'll talk about this in a bit
more detail I think a big and
complicated part of all this is of
course the network one is is your
network encrypted is their passive
listener on there there man in the
middle that's happening here it can your
network handle a dos attack and a handle
the load that needs to be there you have
uptown requirements the network needs to
be able to handle all of these things
right and then as we talked about it as
you move to the cloud
the new model is who can see these
applications think about all the legacy
lift and shift applications that you're
moving to the cloud needs to be safe
behind the walls of EPA and when you
move them to the cloud these legacy
systems can't they don't have
traditional access models right and now
they're on the cloud are they accessible
by anybody and even if it's not a lift
and shift application application is
that a custom built for the web and and
actually i'll have a good point is i'm
not going to steal the sender but you
are very good at application logic right
your developers very good application
logic its security necessarily a strong
point for for what that person does and
so we need to provide tools and things
in that domain so in essence this is a
high-level overview of where things
start to go wrong and in still needs
under right okay good yeah so then what
you write what you're starting to see is
a let's get let's get concrete about the
things that talked about right like
fishing and and still Christians member
here fishing becomes one of the largest
attack vectors against your organization
somebody can either just fake a website
for you to go your employee to go to and
enter the credentials and that's it or
someone steal the token or cookie from
your browser all that so that's all it
takes is for those tokens that token to
be God's a bearer token in essence now
and your account is fished everyone can
access as you the second one is malware
right we see in a lot of our customers
they're saying oh I had a backdoor I
didn't even know about information just
started leaking around the man in the
middle I think of an example actually we
had a customer actually had this problem
during heartbleed somebody used harp
lead to get search from supposedly
protected server and then just even
though the employee that the company's
out the traffic was all encrypted in
HTTPS the tokens after the the keys out
there now people are listening man in
the middle of those attacks right or you
know all of you know companies that have
suffered through dos attacks and have
really suffered through all those things
the access policy right access policy is
in some points it's a choke point you
can start to really enforce access at
these things we'll talk about what we
can do with proxies and of course on the
application side it's very clear that
excellent you know you can have Christ
site scripting attacks we can have
buffer overflows all these types of
things that just end up leaking
information out into the world and so
there are solutions to these problems
and and there are lots of players in
this space but the vendors you go with
need to provide those kinds of solutions
you have to have some sort of fishing
resistant up and said we have a security
key solution which question we'll talk
to in a moment here but the idea should
be that even if your username and
password gets compromised there are
other factors other second factors that
are not compromised alone that they'll
protect access to your application right
device management is another key area
where there's a lot of opportunity for
protection here in two ways to think
about it one is in the configuration of
your device I need and I'm enforcing
that antivirus needs to be on this
device I need to make sure that
antivirus is there for example or in the
state of the device even if everything
seems like it's set properly is there
screen lock enabled is it in the right
IP address those are the kinds of things
where you need to be able to say is this
device even if it's the right person on
a corporate issued device is a device in
a good state before I allow access the
other part of the this this layered cake
if you will is this idea that you have
well configured TLS managing the search
for all the TLS and everything is a hard
job and a lot of DevOps people are
focused on keeping everything up but not
necessarily in managing these certs
protecting against dos attacks and
things like that that needs to be we
need to make sure that we offer those
solutions right out of the box for you
to me the most interesting part of this
talk because it's one of the products I
work on is if this idea that you have a
proxy choke point that controls access
right you can do a lot of things at this
layer the first thing you can do is you
can start to take the context of the
request is it coming from the right IP
address is it coming from a safe device
that was the user strong off in all of
this and say yes all these boxes checked
let's allow access to go to go on here
but the proxy also does other things
right it says unlike a VPN model in the
old world you can say you now you can
create more fine-grained access control
with these places the ERP app is out of
bounds for me the CRM app isn't you can
start to set those types of access
policies of this proxy and then of
course you should always continuously be
doing scans of your of your applications
that are running in the cloud making
sure that there's no security
vulnerabilities or anything that's gone
wild out there and so we envision a
world where an administrator or
developer even concept to set very
simplified policies that have very
powerful consequences an example of that
is I want for access to my ERP
application I only want members of my
finance group to access this right no
setting up VPN is no making sure every
the right place only members of my
replicate a finance team should be able
have access they should only be coming
from corp devices ashanti coming from in
in corp network or from the right
geographies i want to make sure they are
for they say they are and i want to make
sure that's coming across a secure
network those are very key policies that
want to set they should be check check
check check and you should be getting
that out of the box google cloud
especially after the announcements we
made yesterday fighting resources talk
starts to offer a lot of solutions in
this space right we introduced the
identity where proxy this is how we want
to control access to applications by
users identities right from well managed
devices watch lots of things that we're
going to start to be doing here we have
an MDM solution already we're going to
offer richer solutions coming out
shortly you know it from certain
geographies we want to make sure you can
start to set policies that say Corp
network not Corp networks not from
sanction countries from sanction
countries whatever it happens to be we
also want you to be able to use security
key to be and I know that's what Caesar
unfishable but very fishing resistant in
accessing these applications and the
load balancers have to provide a lot of
things right it provides your TLS
termination you want to be able to be a
hardened against these attacks we offer
solutions in these spaces so a lot of
these things we already provide here you
see the green and white boxes what we're
now introducing today or actually
yesterday are two new parts of this
chain which we think gives you full
coverage from end to end and it's not
that the journey ever ends but now we
think we have a lot of the the boxes
checked in total security first the
security key enforcement and the second
is identity aware proxy and so we'll
talk about these two products briefly
and then let Dale come up on afterwards
and talk to how these things become
extra Lee useful in the wild so i'll
start with the identity of where proxy
and then hand it over to christian we
call I ap for this loving name which is
this part of the cycle I ap is actually
a the idea is very simple but what if
the value provided is actually quite
huge here but what we want to do is we
want to give administrators and
developers a way of configuring access
controls by the people who are supposed
to get access those applications right
you set users you set the group's you
set the application is supposed to reach
to and IA enforces that access control
and well the value here is that the devs
can focus on the logic of their
applications we take care of all the
other things that go along and around
security of that and the administrator
has full control in that world right and
so the experience is actually very
simplified here right the administrator
comes in this is not actual policy
syntax but I wanted to use it to
highlight how things work here right
that you have you specified very clearly
members of the finance team can access
my ear fee application that's it it's as
simple as that instead of you've seen
the UI you can see it's actually
literally you pick your after the
application back-end you click the
slider to activate add your users and
you're up and running it's that quick so
then the next day as the user actually
comes going here comes Sarah she's a
member of the Finance Group we can
validate that I shouldn't go back as she
is in fact to see chef see if we don't
know who she is we all the center back
to your SS 0 or IDP to validate or if
she def it's a Google identity we can
send it to the Google identity system
she verifies validate so she is once I
AP does that check and says yes this is
in fact Sarah yes she actually belongs
the IEP grew she actually belongs to the
finance team the next thing to do is
does he actually belong on does she get
access I if he makes that check and says
yes Sarah does in fact get access to the
ERP application and so she's in and
she's running in her life should go on
very smoothly and easily and we avoid
the unintended access consequence which
is to say but she hasn't been specified
to access the CRM application so she
doesn't get access with CRM application
it's as simple as that and so that is in
essence how we want to deliver I ap as
the first step of me beyond court vision
to a lot of our customers that are
running in the cloud and I think it's
the second part of that a Christian will
come up and talk about strong up hello
can you hear me non yep hi hi everyone
I'm Christian brand thanks i meet i'm a
product manager on the team at Google
responsible for identity and security
and over the next couple of minutes I
really want to be focusing on secure
user authentication it's kind of the
green part there and how we can make
sure that we're providing access in this
model to the rightful user so fishing
and I'm sure you all know exactly what's
fishing is but just kind of to recap
briefly rides fishing and attacks where
a bad guy quick so user into revealing
their sensitive credentials such as a
username and a password
to the wrong website accounted for
two-thirds of the security incidents in
2015 according to a verizon data breach
report now other than fishing there's
also other types of compromises
passwords get compromises through reuse
and interception but the industry has a
solution to this problem right the
industry solution is multi-factor
authentication but the problem is that
most of the multi-factor authentication
solutions today rely on just another
form of a password the one-time password
and these really are just as trivially
easy to fish as the user standard
password and it doesn't really provide
adequate protection for high-value
accounts so Google's research have also
shown that even with all the user
education going on and crying to warn
users against phishing attacks and
educate them users will stall full for
sophisticated phishing scams about half
of the time so this really is a systemic
industry problem so the mechanism we use
at Google to achieve secure and fishing
resistant plugins is based on a tiny
piece of hardware arm we call the
security key you can see that on the
right so security keys form the basis of
all authentication at Google and if you
use google as your identity provider you
can also benefit from this same advanced
protection so let's briefly take a
couple of moments here and go through
how the security keys really work and
achieve this kind of elevated level of
protection against phishing so typically
if we look at what we're presenting here
right there is a user the user is trying
to get access to a server what normally
happens in single factor authentication
world a password gets sent from the left
to the right and that provides the user
access to the resource right pretty
simple so let's take a look at these
next few slides right so we see
something on the screen here and I'm
going to show you something else now
what change anyone have an idea what
changed between these two slides so let
me call that out the your elbow right
that's fishing right so a user thinks on
there the exactly the right side through
going to input their credentials but
actually they're not really on
rightful website because users were kind
of trained to look at the URL bar and
things like that but it's a lot of
cognitive loads for users and most of
the time they actually like we said with
our research as proven in about half of
the time users actually don't check for
all these little details on the pages
and they still actually end up in these
traps that malicious bad guy set for
them and they give away credentials to
some phishing websites now one of the
questions is like how did they get to
this page in the first place they didn't
go to miss pipe right so typically and
I'll show that in a second year right so
typically let's just talk through the
phishing attack right pretty simple user
enters password password goes to bad guy
bad guy sent spots or a tooth frightful
server and bad guys logged in right
pretty straightforward so let's look at
the next slide and how the user actually
gets to this bad websites in the first
place well normally that's kind of the
the model right someone gets sent an
email the email looks like it's from the
right party the email might say
something like hey you know you need to
immediately change your password because
someone tried to log into your account
the user would click on the link
unknowingly going to a phishing websites
because there's kind of puts it hard for
the user to figure out whether this
email really came from a trusted source
and there's other protections of course
that's in place there but that's a bear
basic level user Aston is still kind of
full for these attacks and that's kind
of what we see it's like I said about
two-thirds of incidents in 2015 which as
a result of this kind of attack so we
really need to do something to try and
protect so let's now look at security
keys very briefly so um what we have is
the user here on the left the user is
trying to sign in to website but in
addition to only sending the password
something else happens here the user
typically has a security key security
keys come in various different form
factors we have USB based security keys
we've had them for a while we now also
have security keys that can be attached
over NFC Near Field Communication and
bluetooth bluetooth low energy or ble so
this security key on the left hand side
is worth the user when they try to sign
in but the security key also contains a
cryptographic key it contains a unique
private key
and there is an Associated key at the
server called the public key and this
kind of key pair of God generated at
some point in the past when the user
registered their axes for this specific
service when their password was set up
they also registered there a security
key which created these two key pairs
and the public he got sent to the server
and the private key got generated and
stored on the token so what happens now
when the user tries to sign in there is
actually a password that goes down yes
that's your first factor but there is
also an additional signed very important
cryptographic assertion that goes from
the device to the server and this a
cryptographic assertion has three very
important components so the first one is
the promise that the user was physically
present and the way we promise that is
by simply actually allowing the user to
only generate an assertion or the device
to only generate an assertion when the
button was clicked on the token so
you'll see what these security keys they
normally have a capacitive touch or a
resistive touch or a physical button
that need to be pressed so at the point
in time where you wanna sign in you need
to physically press this button so
that's the promise that a user was
present at the time of log in at the
machine there is a server challenge and
this is kind of just farther than usual
crypto response to protect against
replay attack so the server sends a
challenge to the device and then the
token responds back with that specific
challenge so in in the response but
that's not the most important the most
important part of this and the thing
that really protects the user against
phishing at this point is that third
line there that we kind of call the
origin so what happens is when the user
is on a specific website on the left
hand side here oh they're trying to
access a certain service the URI and the
EV specific etl d or the the top-level
domain normally +1 and in the case of
the protocol that I have here that's
kind of specified by the specific
request but when the user is on a
website that websites for lack of a
better term that they're on actually
gets incorporated in the digital
signature that goes back to the to the
server so whatever the user is on on the
left hand side gets incorporated into
the signature and sent to the server say
if the user is on the rightful google
website the Google server on the right
hand side will look at the signature and
say yep that's what I expect I
spectively user to be on this specific
website that's what the signature
presented to me so I'll allow the user
to sign in so let's look at a phishing
attack and how the security key in this
case defeat the phishing attack that we
saw a little earlier so we have the same
example we've got the security key on
the left we have the corresponding
public key on the right we have the user
trying to sign in there is a fishing guy
in the middle user is on the wrong URL
as we can see so what happens is we send
the password as preneur Mille over to
the bad guy the bad guy presents the
crypto challenge to the TV to the user
the user clicks the button on their
security key a session gets generated
and the assertion that the bad guy gets
at this point is obviously an assertion
for the wrong website so when the bad
guy sends that assertion back to the
rightful relying party or the server
Google in this case Google will look at
that and say hey I don't expect this
origin to be google com I'm Google and
at that point in time they will simply
reject the login so it's really actually
pretty straightforward if you kind of
break it up like this but the point is
the bad guy in the middle cannot tamper
with that the message block that gets
sent from the client to the server
because it's digitally signed using this
private key that was generated out of
band previously so that's kind of the
protocol in general right so pretty
straightforward but really pretty
powerful so now the question is how does
this technology apply to you well we
launched something we call security
enforcement about a month ago we spoke
about it earlier as well and this really
allows you as an administrator to
enforce the use of security keys on
certain groups of users or in cervical
certain our organizational units and by
enforcing security keys you make it
really hard for bad guys to Creek your
users into falling for phishing scams
because even if the user is on a website
that they shouldn't be on the security
key will generate the signature that
your server will be able to detect as
kind of fraudulent and the other thing
is security keys of course now supported
on both desktop and mobile we had
security key support for a while at
Google it was mainly around USB but we
now also have support on Android and iOS
devices using NFC and Bluetooth
protocols there
so then turning it on for a subset of
users is really straightforward
typically it's a one click event where
you configure its you said verification
you now have the option to say hey I
want only security keys on these groups
of users and at that point it will be
enforced and all the other controls that
goes together with this onboarding users
taking them to the onboarding process
that's kind of all part and parcel of
this kind of one click event so kind of
is the last slide here strike one of the
one of our customers is rolled out
security enforcement to all of their
users and they really believe that this
is the perfect way to balance ease of
use with increased account security
across both desktop and mobile devices
so in summary if you're worried about
fishing implement security enforcement
and if you want controlled access to
applications from the internet implement
identity aware proxy and with that let
me hand you over to Dale from vin testa
to talk about their implementation thank
you thank you so for these slide
transitions work all right so what I'm
gonna start off with is the obligatory
marketing slide but I think it's
actually pretty relevant in this case to
understand kind of who our customers are
and so the way we describe our business
is we strive to be the number one
platform for selling digital solutions
to small business or local business and
so if you want to think of who is the
end user of our software in a lot of
cases it's a small business and so this
is not necessarily the high-value target
but it is often also sometimes a person
that's not super familiar with digital
because one of the things we're helping
these people with is basically a digital
transformation for them to use the word
that I guess we use here well we're
talking about these guys used to buy
yellow page ads they used to buy all
these you know traditional media and
things like that and they're looking for
all customers in mice but basically in
my store or even better some of them
want customers on a website they don't
have so we essentially help to provide
those tools to small business and the
way we do that is eighty-five percent of
them purchase from an actual physical
person that comes and calls on them so
we do this through resellers so we have
1,700 brands that actually have sales
people that represent our software as
like their brand and then sell this to
small business and so for us security we
consider a pretty
Orton and we consider security actually
is like one of those features that it's
like performance in a lot of ways in
that you know you don't really know it's
a problem until you don't have it and
then you know you realize that you
actually did want performance or
security but but unlike performance if
if you don't deliver on security it's
pretty hard to actually regain trust
because if you have a slow website and
you improve the performance I mean
that's cool your users are probably okay
with that but if you lose all their data
or they use their bank password to log
into your website and you lost it you
know that's kind of a big deal and so I
guess looking at this when we read that
the beyond court paper like there's a
couple of things that we thought were
pretty striking on it and you know it
actually put you know you guys all said
you've heard of the beyond court paper
like how many of you have actually read
to be on court paper so I don't see a
ton of hands but so i thought i would
give like a couple of key pieces to the
beyond court paper and I know that we
talked earlier a meet with saying like
you know we wanted to change a little
bit about VPNs and I mean the a lot of
people are thinking like you know I have
you know we're switching it cloud so
VPNs are too complicated and so that's
why we don't want to use VPNs and I
think that you're I mean we're actually
missing the point if that's what you're
thinking in terms of VPNs the real issue
is that on a VPN it's more of a
traditional like hard candy approach i
think they call it and so the idea is
once you're on the network you have
access to everything and so really what
we're saying here is if your application
design involves a VPN and it's for a new
application you're probably thinking
about it wrong because what you're
basically saying is is that i want to
protect access to my entire application
as long as i can do that i'm going to be
okay on security and the way that I
think that is it's not in the beyond
core paper but it was something I she
heard a docker con last year I don't
remember the speaker to give him credit
but what what he said is that if you're
if you're thinking about preventing
hackers that you probably have already
lost the game really the answer you want
to do is like when you get hacked you
want to minimize the damage and you want
to make sure that other things don't get
hacked because again especially for us
in this picture that meat was showing
before I don't have control over their
devices I don't have control over a lot
of stuff so my goal is to actually make
it so
that you know if one of my users does is
actually get attacked they don't get
access to other users data so we can
kind of minimize damage in that sort of
way and then the other part is to make
it harder because again it is unlikely
that a nation state is choosing to
attack you know one of our small
business customers who runs a hardware
shop in Delaware to access his
information about his advertising or
website but at the same time I don't
want to trivialize the security problem
either because it still is important and
so for this what we talk about is
essentially a service proxy and this is
a amuse talking a little bit about this
earlier in terms of like you this is uh
I mean we simplified a little bit in
terms of saying this is just I ap and
I'll get into that in a second but like
as an example on our cloud that we run
our entire infrastructure is on google
cloud so I don't have an on-premise
deployment and I don't have another
cloud so those are not the reasons for
me switching to this sort of a
deployment I control access to all of
all of my micro services and my
deployments through a service proxy so
that actually means that all of my
services are publicly accessible and so
we don't have a VPN we don't have
special networks and things like that
they're all accessible this way and so
what I do is I use the multi-factor
authentication specifically for access
to gcp and I do actually use service
accounts and I encrypt my traffic
between all of my micro services and so
if you're I mean how many of you here
have like a micro service architecture
that you guys run like we got we got a
few hands so so quite of you probably
have like a like a MOT like I've guess
so they're showing how many people then
have a mana list that they run ok so
then we've got about half the people
here that run software but anyways
either case what you have is you
essentially even in a monolith it's
likely that you have segments of your
code that you're exposing maybe not as a
like maybe you could be pedantic and you
don't want to call it a micro service
but it is a separate piece of code but
we try to think of is that encrypting
between those systems is actually really
important and trying to make sure that
you have identities and everything else
like that again because then if you
suffer like a vulnerability or somebody
gains access that they shouldn't you
know they can't just sit there and
browse your whole network and see all
your traffic and so for us the way we do
that is we just make it publicly
accessible and so it's pretty it makes
everybody all the engineers and
everybody think about like wait a minute
this is a public facing service I
obviously have to encourage things I
obviously need identity and I can't
trust that this is a VPN so it actually
it leads to some better practices and so
what we actually said is like how many
how do we consider yourselves like a
fairly well-versed like understanding
security and then is there anybody in
the audience here that like self
security has their product like two
other vendors so it's like one of the
thing that we look at is like we don't
do that and so for us if you're a vendor
of security this solution i'm talking
about you there's potentially this is
something that you like you don't
necessarily want to do what I'm talking
about but what I say is I might delegate
identity to Google it's a really hard
problem and when Christians up here you
here I'm talking about you know we've
got special keys of hardware we've got
signing we're thinking about fishing and
then you know I'm sitting the audience
and I'm like this sounds great but like
what happens if somebody hacks dns I i
don't know like these are the kind of
questions that I don't want to have my
engineers really worrying about and so
what we actually do is we delegate our
security to Google and again I don't
delegate all of my security so then what
it becomes is I have to think about
security I still I do consider you need
to be at some level an expert on
security to understand like what is
Google doing and am i comfortable with
that and making sure that I mean I'm
covering the other stuff that Google
doesn't and so in terms of like the
security the words that I enjoy that
google gave out and I'm not I don't
think it's fair to give them credit for
the the naming but we finally switch
from authentication and authorization to
identity and access management I'm
suspecting it's one of the other cloud
vendors that came up with that but I
think the idea is it's a really good
distinction because they don't both
start with off and so it makes it easier
to actually have a conversation because
you don't have that cognitive load of
liquid are we talking about so i
delegate identity to google because it's
probably the hardest part and in terms
of your security it's one of the most
important pieces because if i have a
really great access management system
that's very good at controlling whether
it's whether a meat has access to
documents or whether i have access to
documents but the system actually has a
really hard time determining whether
it's me or meet accessing it much
sure she's kind of wasted time right so
like for us we think did identities one
of the core parts just because you get
it right doesn't mean you're secure but
if you get it wrong you're pretty much
not secure and so we consider that is
something we choose to Google as a
partner for this that to make these
things more secure and so in terms of
the what we also do is at this point my
users my small small businesses they log
into my system so I've got usernames and
passwords and so what we're doing is
we're switching a single sign-on and so
that means like everybody here is
probably use that in terms of like for
single sign-on is one of those terms
that gets thrown around and oftentimes
abused in terms of but what actually I
think the the terms of you if you look
it up its original version what is
talking about is signing with gmail
would be an easy way to think about our
sign in with Facebook or sign in with
github or something like that what
you're essentially saying is that I'm
going to sign on with one provider and
I'm going to get access to multiple
services so the good part and this is
that again we're trusting Google to
manage the all that extra work of
tracking devices check and security keys
check and passwords and then eventually
at the end we say when a request comes
in we say you know is this guy who he
said it is and google says yeah I mumble
pretty confident this is who he says he
is now there's a few issues that we can
talk about this you know I would like to
have some more because right now what we
have is how many of you guys use G sweet
so we've got a few people here how you
guys use two-factor with your g sweet so
we've got a few people that do one of
the things that you'll find that GP does
for us or you know which is kind of
interesting is it has this sub you know
it assigns the the level of trust
required to an actual user and so what
it's going to say is like hey Dale is is
a guy who has access to quite a few you
know top secret documents and so we want
to make sure he has to factor but then
what that actually means for me is now
when I want to you know SSO into you
know stack overflow I need to factor and
so like one of the things we would like
is the ability to say like you know I
can as an application say like what
level of trust by care about because and
that could be either at an application
level like I ap talks about or even
within an app because you could imagine
on google docs it's frustrating if i
have to have like security keys and a
bunch of other stuff when i want to read
the social committee meeting minutes and
the same level of trust
required for other documents so some of
that stuff I think there's some room to
move forward but specifically around
making it easier for these users and so
when I was talking earlier about the the
service proxy which is that I AP one of
the things that's important to see is
that we actually use kind of a couple
pieces here but like a load balancer is
obviously another important component if
your service has some be like more than
one computer that's or vm or container
or whatever this going to be serving it
it's like a layer 7 load balancer plus
80 80 is actually in terms of if you're
reading the beyond core paper that
that's kind of how we view what the
service proxy in that picture is and
this is what we use in front of
basically all of our services on on
Cooper Nettie's that we run in gke and
so this is this is what's implementing
that particular piece and I think I've
got a beautiful animation hear that a
lot of the Google marketing guys put
together it's like so this is over time
but earlier and then boom it breaks that
first piece up into two so this like you
guys have all probably use the the layer
7 load balancer it's really not that bad
an enemy comes up here and shows that
you just like to type in a policy that
work so pretty well this stuff is it's
actually pretty it is pretty easy to get
started with and add some pretty
powerful rules to add this security and
then what Cloud endpoints does for us is
we implement our micro services using
grp see and what you'll find is a lot of
our customers do not like or use grp see
and for us we don't really want to have
to you know we want to lower our
performance or our expectations of our
own api's by implementing them all as
json rest and so what we do is we use
the Cloud endpoints to provide a JSON
gateway it provides monitoring it
provides there's a lot of great
functionality the Cloud endpoints
provides it's just a side car running
along with our or pods and so that's
kind of what we offer there and so then
every single one of the request is
coming in here we've got an identity
associated with it we've got a Cloud
endpoints here to manage some of the
monitoring and the other things and then
our applications are left to manage the
access and so again we have a coarse
grain level for my AP but we have again
we can implement our own specific access
requirements at the service levels and
so I guess one of the things you look at
here sorry I guess I've got the
beautiful thing down here
we use these keys again to protect
accounts their office like as an example
I have access to delete gcp projects and
so for us we consider it important that
I do use two-factor some of the stuff
that that I think we were talking about
earlier with the security keys like this
is great it there and I know like a lot
of people will say like you can't say
the words unfishable which i think is uh
is fair I think we get into things like
the the security keys actually on these
guys in the in the YouTube at schneider
they actually support client certs in
the way that we're talking about signing
there you can actually get down to like
a TLS level and do some of those things
too so it's pretty cool what some of
these things support and it's important
to our business because again it's not a
small business that I have to
necessarily protect at this level but
it's the basically the people at my
office that I need to make sure this
sort of stuff happens but obviously that
only works if i can actually delegate
login into my system for my users to
google and so we've already done this so
what this means is if you're a user in
any of my systems that has access to
administrative functionality if we
actually require you to have both
logging into our system and a google
login and so what it means is that i can
manage min access to my entire
application through g sweet because i
can just like disable g sweet accounts
and all of a sudden now you have no
access to any more of the admin's and
then in terms of what we actually see is
really exciting is our ability to throw
in this the second factor and the the
one thing that we lack right now as a
part of this is when i get an identity
I've nobility to say that hey because
this identity have to factor on it so
it's kind of up to me to make sure that
like I've implemented to factor on my
organization and the functions that I
want to be to factor protected that I
have coordinated that it would be really
nice if like when an identity came in
Google could say like hey here's the
level of trust associated with this so I
didn't have to make sure that I've got
it right in two different places so
there's a whole bunch of different
things that I think I want to summarize
a couple I want to make sure I didn't
miss any of them here but like the idea
of using client certs specifically to
simplify I think people talked about at
one of the talk sighs that there was a
you know that web version of the best
practice for OAuth should we be
following and in some ways for us like
services service is simplified if you
just use client
shirts in terms of you know I have a
have a client cert that exists on one of
these you know either it's protected in
my service if it's a back-end service or
maybe it's on my yubikey or something
like that it's something that we would
really like and it's not something
that's supported right now in terms of
like if you're using a layer 7 load
balancer so you can't actually do that
for some of these things and then the
other thing that's that's the kind of
blood is like grp c is not supported
right now on the layer 7 load balancer
so while the picture up here is showing
a layer 7 load balancer we use that for
our JSON gateways and the grp see stuff
goes to a layer for load balancer so
that kind of stuff is something that we
end up having a compromise in there um
and then I guess some of the other stuff
is we would like to see this this
ability to do you know more metadata
about the identity because right now
it's just like I get an email address
basically is what I get for an identity
and it would be nice to support things
like like we said the metadata about
like this level of trust or even in the
case of a like again I will call it a
stacked identity which is like I'm
microservice one thing that I want to do
this work on behalf of Dale and I
actually have both of those both those
piece of information that could be
helpful and so those are some of the
things I'm looking at in terms of our
organization and so again what you're
going to find is that the conclusions
are actually very similar that we came
to that amiche talked about earlier or
as a Christian I think was Christian
actually summarized it up we've
implemented security key enforcement
internally and we've implemented I
identity aware proxy and then what we
specifically done is we need to SSO for
all of our identity internally and our
goal is over the coming year to start to
roll more of that out to our customers
but adding support for sso logins and
then eventually removing support for
username and password based logins so
that we can delegate to trusted sources
that have two factor auth such as github
or or Google and so for our end users we
probably I guess we'll see like what the
adoption rates are and see how many
providers we end up having to go with to
make sure we cover all the small
businesses but for internal since we
have G suite and a large percentage of
our resellers do too it's likely that we
will choose to school to do our identity
for that so at this point i figured i'd
ask if there's any questions on some of
this stuff i find this stuff really
exciting i find it kind of interesting
in terms of reading about all this stuff
and you know
these these standards around encryption
work and then not having to implement
half of them because Google does it for
us but it I guess there's a there's a
microphone here in the middle so if if
anybody had any questions they be
appreciated
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]